[Musik]
organisation und alles in der jetzt klar
dass ich das gerät hat ein problem vor
dem herunterladen
und tatsächlich corine wird und
anna-lisa zionist fenster
es macht schon mal eine woche später hat
mir ein sondern die nachbarin gemacht
ist all das hatte sich der baselbieter
pro rad job anders vorgestellt
ausgerechnet hier auf der schwarzmeer
halbinsel krim einem hotspot der
geopolitik wollte er ein haus bauen mit
ein paar ferienwohnungen um zusammen mit
seiner frau carina das leben und den
ruhestand zu genießen
[Musik]
vielleicht das letzte mal hinein sagte
kretschmann als hausgemacht seien viel
bisher wohl erschossen
[Musik]
das erste mal traf ich roland job im
sommer 2009 10
damals lebte zusammen mit seiner frau
carina in läufelfingen auf diesem
campingplatz
[Musik]
der baselbieter hat alles auf eine karte
gesetzt wohnung verkauft seine metallbau
firma verkauft und eine neue gegründet
jobs krim reise war es schwierig unsere
vom raus hier fühl mich ganz ganz das
ganz ganz kleine und plastik ja
natürlich ich war unzufrieden haben wir
jetzt schon genug ich habe gelernt oder
gewonnen und das speziell haben der mann
ihr holz machen will
in ihrer heimat ich weiß nie was dort
interessant
heute abend fliegen die beiden auf die
krim die alte heimat von carina vor
sieben jahren haben sie sich im internet
kennengelernt und später geheiratet
für roland ist das haus auf der krim
eine flucht nach vorne
nach einem herzinfarkt und einen bürgen
out ist er überzeugt dass er auf der
krim ein längeres leben vor sich hat als
in der schweiz
was nicht so medizinisch versorgen
das wird die papiere gefragt
dann sind noch mehr vertragen wenn er
stolz die schweiz bleibe werde so wieder
geschafft hat die und wollte dort werden
fragt ein echter entweder durch die krim
und weniger stress kurz klima druck
das ist das auch mit philosophie
[Musik]
das ziel von carina und roland die stadt
hier fattoria ein touristenort im westen
der krim
die gäste kommen vor allem aus russland
westliche und ukrainische besucherinnen
und besucher sind hier selten geworden
eine folge der internationalen
sanktionen
wenn die jobs in der stadt sind wohnen
sie in eine mietwohnung
roland und carina sind schon ein paar
tage vor mir auf die krim gekommen
mit einem flug über moskau damit
verletzten sie ukrainisches recht was
sie in kauf nehmen
[Musik]
ich selber fahre auf dem offiziellen weg
durch die ukraine in richtung kleben der
krim ist ein streitobjekt zwischen
russland und dem westen
seit der annexion der ukrainischen
halbinsel durch russland vor sechs
jahren ist hier faktisch eine grenze
zuerst geht es an den ukrainischen
behörden vorbei dann an den russischen
wie die meisten hier bringe ich die paar
hundert metern niemandsland zu fuß
hinter mich eine spannungsgeladene
stimmung
mit allen kontrollen und befragungen
kann das stunden dauern
von reisen auf die krim red die
offizielle schweiz übrigens ab aus sicht
der schweiz und vieler anderer länder
bin ich hier völkerrechtlich nach wie
vor in der ukraine
aber das ist russland das die kinder
jetzt seit unter seiner kontrolle hat
winter 2014
russland steckt militärische
sondereinheiten auf die ukrainische klub
nach einem umstrittenen referendum
erklärt der kreml die krim als teil
russlands viele campbewohner
unterstützen das und sie tun es bis
heute andere insbesondere viele unter
den muslimischen quinta taten wm sich
dagegen eine illegale annexion sagt die
mehrheit der eu staaten
mit kampfjets und schwerem
kriegsmaterial demonstriert der
russische präsident wladimir putin
seither seine bereitschaft die creme mit
allen mitteln zu verteidigen
auf der insel führte er ein autoritäres
regime ein
russland hat inzwischen geschätzte 20
milliarden franken hier investiert unter
anderem in neue straßen und eine brücke
zum russischen festland die ukraine und
der westen haben mit sanktionen reagiert
so können roland und carina auf der krim
zum beispiel ihre schweizer handys oder
ihre kreditkarten nicht gebrauchen
doch trotz internationaler sanktionen
sind die regale in den verkaufsläden
hier voll die renten und löhne auf der
krim sind dank russischer gelder
gestiegen
aber auch die preise sind in die höhe
geschnellt es gibt viel bürokratie und
korruption
insgesamt ist die wirtschaftliche bilanz
der aktion für russland ziemlich
ernüchternd roland job sagt er wisse
wenig über die politische situation
geäußert sich pragmatisch
[Gelächter]
in zukunft will jetzt so große sehr viel
investiert also ganzen infrastruktur
tourismus zunächst besser als russland
ist
[Musik]
die baustelle der jobs liegt etwas
außerhalb der stadt rund zwei kilometer
von mir getrennt
seit 2017 bauen sie hier
geplant sind eine wohnung für sich und
vier ferienwohnungen zu wenig gut aus
auf next firmierte das wird auch nicht
lange nicht lange doch mal komplett
machen die eine stoppen
[Musik]
das vergisst dass eine neue technologie
dass dieser ohne und ja dass er schon
gemacht und überall landen und
kraftstrom verbleibt aber legen ein
schwert das schon damit dass sie denn
die kalina mitmacht wenn doch die art
will hoch natürlich leben geben die
schweiz
[Musik]
carina ist noch nicht davon überzeugt
wieder in ihre ehemalige heimat krim zu
ziehen
sie hat im baselbiet eine teilzeit job
als pflegehelferin bei der spitex denen
wie sie nicht aufgeben
aber wenn sie auf der krim ist übernimmt
sie aufgrund ihrer sprachkenntnisse viel
von der organisation
[Musik]
aktuell gibt es ein problem mit den
armenischen bauarbeiter zwei wochen
[Gelächter]
15 jahre hat der roland job nicht mehr
geraucht
die ständigen verzögerungen sind nerven
zerrt und gehen an den geldbeutel
der traum vom ruhigen leben auf der krim
droht zu platzen
die größte herausforderung ist der
streit mit der nachbarin
sie reicht immer wieder beschwerden bei
den behörden ein ruft die polizei und
achtet penibel darauf dass die
bauvorschriften eingehalten werden
[Musik]
aber haben wir sehr gut geklappt 22
ägypter verschafft und dort nachbarin
des polizeiapparats die akte unter net
sou so dass sika bewilligungen ohne
bewilligung das normal ist dass hier
alles in halblinker ich fehler gemacht
habe
also sehen jetzt nach vorne liegt wachse
weil ich das problem das wir sehen gute
zahlen und haben darüber hat man sie
nicht vertragen so machen das ist mir
selber aus meiner zeit in russland und
der ukraine weiß ich dass beim bauen
vieles nicht angemeldet wird
ich möchte diese nachbarin gerne mal
treffen
klopf lauter das von ihnen dort ist doch
kein wohnhaus
schauen sie mainz an das ist ein
wohnhaus oder diejenigen der nachbarn
aber sie hier haben kommerzielle
ferienwohnungen die wollen hier business
machen aber ein business mit 30 gästen
das wird es nicht geben
es gibt nunmal gesetze in unserem land
und an diese muss man sich halten
wir kamen aus der hauptstadt sind für
rock ball und haben das haus extra hier
gebaut in der einöde etwas weiter vom
mehr weg weil wir keine touristen um uns
haben wollten wir wollen ruhe wenn sie
ein business wollen wieso gehen sie dann
nicht ans meer bauen weil es dort teurer
ist sie wollen sparen auf kosten meiner
nerven
inzwischen haben die jobs ihr haus
offiziell als kommerzielles ferienhaus
angemeldet
dafür müssen sie jetzt mehr steuern
zahlen
klar ist den unbürokratischen weg zu
bauen wird es hier mit dieser nachbarin
für die baselbieter wohl kaum mehr geben
suchen und finden etwa als große welle
bearbeiten und der zeit sie im
gazastreifen brief geschrieben
vermehrte ablagen und zu bewahren als
wären sie weiterkommen
das habt ihr das gestein dank ihres
rechners richtige
[Musik]
wie viel sie hier investiert haben
wollen die jobs nicht sagen
aber es ist mehr als geplant
[Musik]
nebst dem schicksal der familie job
interessiere ich mich auch für die
politische situation auf der krim
ich erfahre dass zwei der arbeiter
krimtataren sind viele krimtataren seien
seit der annexion durch russland in
einer schwierigen situation heißt es
könnt ihr mir erzählen wie es den
krimtataren heute geht das ist so eine
sache
wir haben ja kinder die machen noch ihre
ausbildung ist das gefährlich zu reden
nicht dass ich mich fürchten würde aber
sie wissen ja es kann allerhand
passieren
dann geben sie mir den kontakt eines
taten führers der offene rede
rund 200.000 taten leben auf der krim
etwa zehn prozent der gesamtbevölkerung
gemäss russische menschenrechts
organisationen unter uno sind die
tataren seit der machtübernahme durch
russland politischen repressionen
ausgesetzt
kritisiert werden unter anderem
willkürliche verhaftungen und folter
der regionale parteien vertreten sind
derzeit wenig raum für politische
forderungen wie war die annexion für sie
emotional
das war damals ein großer schock für uns
wir haben offiziell gesagt dass wir die
annexion nicht anerkennen und unsere
rechte verteidigen
aber dann wurde unsere politische
volksvertretung der match liess von den
russen verboten
und wie leben die taten jetzt auf der
krim
was soll ich sagen ich selber erkläre es
unseren leuten immer so was hast du
schafe dann schau nach ihnen
erzieher und ernähre deine kinder wir
rufen dich nicht zum protest auf hast du
ein gewächshaus dann pflanze gemüse an
erzieher deine kinder und gäbe wir
werden diese zeit überstehen wenn der
protest beginnt rufen wir dich aber
unter den derzeitigen machthabern ist
das zwecklos
sie finden sich sofort hängen dir
irgendetwas an und dann sperren sie dich
ins gefängnis
viele von uns sitzen im gefängnis
[Musik]
die taten sind größtenteils muslime
ihren glauben dürfen sie relativ frei
ausüben und auch ihre eigene tatarische
sprache sprechen und lehrern details
herrschen der abneigung gegenüber den
russen ist historisch begründet stalin
ließ 1944 praktisch die gesamte
tatarische bevölkerung deportieren
erst gegen ende der sowjetunion durften
sie wieder zurück auf die krim
[Musik]
das drama der deputation prägt sie bis
heute
[Musik]
ich bin in dieser region geboren 1944
wurden wir deportiert ich war damals
zwölf jahre alt
sie weckten uns in der nacht warfen uns
aus den häusern und karten und zweck
entschuldigung meine nerven 44 jahre
habe ich dann in usbekistan gelegt dann
durfte ich wieder in meine heimat ich
bin sehr froh in der heimat zu sein
[Musik]
die politischen turbulenzen sind für
roland job der kaum russisch versteht
weit weg er hat genügend sorgen mit der
baustelle gemacht und tritt jedoch
gemacht der bau strapaziert die nerven
des paares
wenn ihr es so macht dann seht ihr jedes
mal das tor einfach damit ihr wisst aber
ich halte mich raus ich bin dann mal weg
macht hier in der mitte wenn du oben den
haaren hast hast du die anschlüsse unten
bei der schublade gelegt etwas wäre
kannst du die schublade ausmachen du
kannst noch etwas machen und das ist
hier hinten versteckt hinter der
schublade
ich möchte das hier bitte im mittel wie
andere auch dass das okay ja ja ja
[Gelächter]
auf wiedersehen ich verreise heute abend
aber mein mann bleibt hier und wilster
abschied vom haus
es ist alles in ordnung eines und
emotional
wir sind schon ruhiger vieles ist getan
entschuldigen sie ich bin etwas müde
wir haben jetzt ein gutes fundament
gelegt
in den nächsten monaten müssen wenn auch
den rohbau fertig machen
ich denke bis neujahr ist es soweit
aber noch ohne den innenausbau
jetzt ist aber die große frage woher wir
für die nächste etappe das geld nehmen
soll
carinas aufenthalte auf der heimischen
creme sind meist kurz im baselbiet
wartete ihre arbeit als spitex
mitarbeiterin roland wird für fast drei
monate alleine hier bleiben
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
es ist oktober im baselbiet
[Musik]
ja ich war ferien gemacht
ja ja ja
[Gelächter]
und der ort für die creme aufgeben
nein nein ich liebe meine arbeit bei der
spitex die möchte ich nicht aufgeben
später schauen wir dann vielleicht aber
ich arbeite mit großem vergnügen und das
möchte ich auch weiterhin tun
[Musik]
in dieser zeit schickt mir roland shop
regelmäßig fotos
es geht gut vorwärts mit dem bau der
selbe fühle sich wohl und würde gerade
am liebsten auf der krim bleiben
aber es zeichnet sich auch schon ab dass
das geld ausgeht
für den vollständigen innenausbau wird
es nicht mehr reicht
[Musik]
es ist mitte dezember 2009 10
ich fahre nochmals zum campingplatz von
läufelfingen roland ist vor kurzem von
der krim zurückgekehrt ich habe eine
schlechte nachricht für ihn
wie ich erfahren habe gibt es
anscheinend sanktionen der schweiz gegen
die creme
so sind dort investitionen verboten und
auch die erbringung touristische
aktivitäten verbot des erwerbs und
ausweitung von beteiligungen an
unternehmen und immobilien auf der krim
russische frau ich bin mit der
logistischen fragen 'warum donna ist
übrigens verbot von dienstleistungen im
zusammenhang mit tourismus bezogenen
aktivitäten auf der krim
nach kurzer besprechung ist klar wie wir
weitermachen wollen
[Musik]
das staatssekretariat für wirtschaft
seco schrieb mir ob ein straftatbestand
vorliege könne nur aufgrund der genauen
kenntnis der fakten und dem vorliegen
entsprechende dokumente beurteilt werden
[Musik]
mittlerweile ist die sommer 2020 roland
job hat wegen der sanktionen reagiert er
hat die job gmbh krim reisen in der
schweiz aufgelöst und in russland eine
neue gegründet
das haus auf der creme läuft ohnehin auf
den namen seiner russischen frau carina
[Musik]
doch für roland ist es auch sonst ein
schweres jahr
die baustelle auf der krim stand wegen
corona still sein geliebter hohen stark
aber das ist noch nicht alles
verständlich die zwei jahre zuvor immer
hand schmerzen und so bin ich natürlich
nicht glaubt natürlich viel geheizt
klangstäben mich unter hunderten
us-flaggen und vielleicht auch zwei
wochen für die brit awards wird mit
das bauprojekt auf der krim wollen beide
unbedingt zu ende führen
es bleibt aber schwierig geld ist fast
keines mehr da roland hat inzwischen
sozialhilfe beantragt
das fest vom bau das fehlerrisiko das
wäre wenn ich 20 hat die wahl vor
unterbrochenen dampfen konnten mehrere
macs oder auf informiert und das thema
wird aber nicht so viel liebe und das
sogar ohne entwickelt aber es wird
hundertprozentig funktioniert die ganze
ist auch die hoffnung stirbt zuletzt
das letzte was ich von carina und roland
gehört habe sie waren zusammen in
hamburg um einen neuen hund zu kaufen
[Musik]
jobs traum vom haus auf der krim ist
noch nicht ganz ausgeträumt
[Musik]